[Music]
in oh no news submitted by cash over
checks a man accidentally tossed out his
life savings along with the recycling
yeah people trust banks huh i dude a lot
of them do this how can you have this
and put it into a recycling how it was
in a shoebox it was a shoebox yeah
guaranteed and I forgot it was in there
you did or if you if you have money at
home just buy like a little safe for
like 100 200 bucks it'll protect them
fires yeah just a little one but you
know if he was saving his money in a
shoebox there you go there's your answer
that's how he threw it out that was his
life savings he was putting his life
savings in a shoebox instead of being
smart and putting into a 401k where it
can grow money or buy a Bitcoin with it
where it's like throwing it on a
rollercoaster organ man accidentally
threw out twenty-three thousand dollars
of savings
he was thankfully reunited with his old
shoebox full of cash oh he got it back
after an employee at a Northern
California recycling facility an honest
employee spotted him good for him
there's still good people on this
project I'm sorry yeah $23,000 how did
he trace it back to them do you well he
cried about it and anyone was like I'll
give it to him so he he thought he was
[ __ ] obviously because the recycling
truck already picked up all the [ __ ]
that he threw I don't think it's all
scumbags at the recycling right of
course for you they're all mafia all the
garbage guys are embracing the recycling
guys you gay
they don't know that bit then another
video for another video he did not just
so yeah so he thought he was [ __ ]
because he thought they're gonna crush
it down or get rid of it or whatever but
it was it had been almost processed by
the time that he contacted the facility
so he got a hold of them and he's like
hey it's kind of funny story I lost 20
grand in my shoe box do you think you
might have it and they were like that's
worse than a needle in a haystack dude
like good luck to you there wasn't able
to chase the truck or was too late like
he was really like yeah I was very teeny
as he should have put a tracker inside
the shoe but a tile he should result in
the shoe box I only know about that now
that's so cool thing I used tile of time
to tell them on what I was so tile is
basically just a device yeah that's
right here so you find your keys and
should find your keys I got one of my
wallet we had is it what you should tile
sponsor me lose my [ __ ] oh it's Barbie
on Netflix - why your eyes you should
make a bracelet for your girlfriend
however where the tiles they put on
their kids do you know when the kids are
on all the time they got another one so
this one's on my keys I think I got out
of my wallet somewhere
yeah nice what Joe make just Italian
with this nice little bin one yeah VIP
she might get kidnapped this shades we
need her so you just I have an app on my
phone
and it just will I just hit ping and
it'll ping it this guy's are dead they
died but this guy what you keep is that
no i order new ones this guy didn't need
that [ __ ] okay so the workers hunted for
it and the box showed up came down the
sorting line and they all knew what the
[ __ ] it was when they saw it
really you must have described it he's
like didn't it's in a 1982 Ninja Turtles
belt what I mean and in big God if he
got it back feels like thank you and you
walked away and he didn't give him any
money or anything that would be great
but they found it and they said that it
was all accounted for except for $320 we
kind of wonder how that was gone
very suspect a pop beers with this to
celebrate I would I would've gave him
$1,000 yeah really I would have [ __ ]
gave him 10 grand yeah no there was 20
25 it was 25 hey dude we found 1500
bucks that's what I woulda said maybe 2
grand finder's fee no no if I if if they
found my money
how would it gave them happened so they
didn't say if he gave money I don't see
any that [ __ ] it's just that everyone
was really happy about it that they
found it you know why because without
them I see it as I would have had zero
money so I wouldn't I would've gave him
a lot of money or maybe maybe I was just
buying strippers oh no no they might be
married maybe maybe I'll do a Subway
sandwich party for them there you go
yeah well he just drove 10 I'll give him
gift cards but he just drove 200 miles
that's a lot of gas money he probably
spent like nearly $300 in yeah damn that
recycling truck travels that [ __ ]
long scissors in Oregon this was our 200
miles well what the block the the
recycling plant was in Northern
California so let me ask you guys this
if you guys were just walking into a
store and you see I don't know I find
your bus in the ground take it from the
register everywhere take it to the
register I feel like that's lucky well
no like a hundred dollar bill on the
ground and it was looks like like I get
you pick it up but if I found ah you
know hundred thousand dollars in a
shoebox
I'd be look I'd look around on it I
don't know I don't think I'd be able to
take it I couldn't take it I can take it
because that could be mob money yeah but
what if you just wait there for like ten
hours and nobody takes it then I would I
would I would have to go I don't know if
I'd give it to the police because I feel
like they may take it but I would say if
someone can describe the shoebox
perfectly with the amount of money
that's in there perfectly how many
[ __ ] shoebox good what and
if you put $25,000 in a shoebox you know
exactly what that shoebox you
to the shoe the brand of the bottoms
because if I say oh I found a shoe box
of 100 K in it who does it belong to I'm
gonna be like me me me me me me me
there's all these stories of people
buying cars right and in the gas tank or
in the trunk or in the seat or whatever
it does like $30,000 drug money and then
what you do with that what do you do you
bought the car you could tell the news
like these [ __ ] morons called the
cops bro
you know why cuz I saw no country for
[ __ ] old man it's not worth it for 30
grand
you don't even knock on the door you
just blows through the [ __ ] the
minute you go and look at the hall guys
the minute he walks in my gas station of
my pan man I bought a car and let's just
say there was 50 grand in the gas tank
or whatever I would not spend that money
mm-hmm for at least a couple years I
just let say wow that's discipline well
I'm in a position where you know you'd
be furious for your life the entire time
though wouldn't because if they showed
up they're like where's my money maybe
like hey dumbass you left it in my car
here you go that's what I'd say to me
[ __ ] morons [ __ ] kill you now but
you're a witness now too I would just
say like you can either walk away or you
can kill me too and all of my friends at
JK clubs
why don't you blow the car up why would
I blow up the car that I just bought are
you gonna buy a new one okay so money
now I'm like now I'm like [ __ ] now I
need to use the cash to prove you know
so so here's the thing if you don't
register it it's not in your name right
but if you do register it but they do
that [ __ ] right there you know when you
buy the car they have that old
typewriter and you're like what are they
doing
yeah if you talking about right I'm like
what the [ __ ] is that are they say are
they sending it but if you blow up the
car then when they look at where the car
is it's like oh it's been blown up oh oh
I just don't know I just think the the
criminal now at that point is an idiot
it's like hang on word look for your car
because why would they put in a car that
can be sold
no no cuz they go to jail or something
so they just put it on a random photo so
so like when they the cops come to sees
like all the stuff not yeah or or what
and I'm just seeing at that point you're
stupid you deserve to lose the money
this is the guys camp all were covered
top 20
oh they're really straight normally he's
not a thief oh cool see that's really
cool almost 26 K yeah that's awesome
you know the most money I've ever seen
like that actually come across like lost
and found wise in cash was uh I was at a
grocery store and I was returning my
cart to the you know where they collect
all of them in the parking lot and the
cart that was last placed in there had a
wallet just placed in that baby seat
area yeah and I was like oh cool there's
a wallet here I should turn it back in
and then I pick it up and I'm like then
the [ __ ] Devlin's I mean it was like
well I want to see who belongs to right
like you know just look at the face of
the person belongs to him oh grandma
lady okay yeah she returned it and I was
like but hold on a second let's see how
much money there is in here just to see
you just to find out in a voice open it
up 100 200 300 320 340 350 355 I was
like walk away with 355 right now and
leave the wallet right there and it's
dark - his night time - I'm like I was
wearing a hat - I was like [ __ ] I could
just go some what I see wallets like
that I can't do it I what did you do
what'd you do I turned it back into the
manager if I don't take it someone else
will found a wallet in New York City I
think it was like me and my sister and
we opened it I there wasn't much cash
but it was like 200 300 bucks
and we found her on Facebook and she
came to my apartment to pick it up which
I thought was surprising she said not
like let's meet up Starbucks
she doesn't have no idea if I'm a weirdo
or not she ended up being like Miss
Switzerland Wow she was the track you
know shoes you're trying I saw it was
like ah this is pearls burning wow this
is the beginning of a fantasy man but
there yeah and then we had a whole
conversation and then I never saw her
again she came she came inside why did
you say you seemed like an interesting
person whatever you want
it works still got a laugh vacuum you
seem like an interesting person so you
know a hot girl is coming then it was
her wallet so our idea was in there too
so you knew a hot chick was coming over
by her ID I just I didn't really think
of anything I just didn't think of it it
was like when you lose [ __ ] like that
I returned someone's passport just
recently don't know I was getting out of
LAX got into my uber and there was a
passport in the back seat and the driver
was like oh I think it belongs to my
last passenger hmm so I ran it back
inside the uber driver was awesome very
nice um he was like oh I dropped him off
at American Airlines saved her trip and
so this person who is going to like
Brazil
Susanoo there one ocean because I went
to the the stand and talked to the
people running the flight attendants
with her and they were like they pulled
it up on the pier like oh this person
needs their passport they're going
they're making connecting flight yeah
more lanes and then from New Orleans
they're going to Brazil or whatever so I
gave it to them and I messaged a dude on
Instagram now I was like finally my blue
checkmark uh message how did you get
there Instagram I had his food I knew
his name his birthday where he was from
[Applause]
so I just googled his name and then BOOM
send a message and then American
Airlines actually was pretty good they
sent the passport to New Orleans with
another pilot wait so he actually got on
the flight without the passport oh he
got his driver's eyes so and they they
got it there and they the gate agent in
New Orleans gave it to him before he
left internationally I will say I also
have a blue checkmark they just give
those things away and also if you want
the good guy award you just got it Jesus
you know what I don't know his name but
if you're out there like this you should
you should give you 20 grand
I do have the messages if you want to
verify he said thank you god you're a
good guy all right we said
[Music]